is the largest emitter in africa due in
large part to the heavy reliance on coal
for power
by closing south africa coal plants
ahead of schedule and investing in clean
power alternatives for the people of
south africa and supporting an equitable
inclusive transition in south africa's
coal sector we're following through on
the pledge the g7 partners made in
cornwall to accelerate the transition
away from coal and developing countries
and i realize the reliance on coal is
consequential fits to accelerate the
transition away from coal and developing
countries and i realize the reliance on
coal is consequential
necessary
is
the example you gave of the new
initiative with south africa is an ex
is an outstanding one an exemplary one
it's an excellent showcase
indeed that the united states the united
kingdom germany france and the european
union are together launching this just
energy transition partnership with south
africa teaming up with president cyril
ramaphosa
financially supporting south africa
making the transition out of fossil fuel
and into clean energy
i think this partnership and i hope it
will be a blueprint
for similar partnerships with other
countries and i look forward to our
discussion
well no fancy production work there but
some very powerful words
well let's hear now from some of the
countries represented here on stage
about the strides they're taking to
transition to clean energy and if i
could call each of you up by turn please
you'll be going to alternate lecterns
and starting with commissioner simpson
of the eu please
if you could join me to come up to this
lecture and here please thank you
excellencies ladies and gentlemen it is
an honor
to be here today representing the
european union at this historic moment
since the last cop in madrid the
european union has made a political
commitment and a legal commitment to
become the first climate neutral
continent by
2050. the european clean deal and the eu
climate law set us
on a clean path for generations to come
as part of this journey we are
decarbonizing our energy system
most eu member states have already fixed
their golexitate
or are working on it
coal producing regions from all parts of
the european union
are already making the transition happen
closing mines and power plants and
developing alternative sustainable
activities to bring new jobs
we are
supporting these efforts through our
unprecedented post-covet clean recovery
program
and a dedicated just transition program
the latter will mobilize up to 75
billion euros to support the most
affected regions sectors and communities
across the eu
goal is the largest
single source of emissions globally and
this has to stop
as an immediate step external goal
finance has to come to an end
the current situation on the energy
markets
is no reason to pause
the coal exit
on the contrary it shows the urgency to
accelerate the rollout
of clean energy solutions and
dramatically reduce our reliance on
fossil fuels
the european example shows it can be
done
today one third of our electricity
already comes from renewables in 2030 it
will be two-thirds
and the use of gold will be history in
many parts of europe
but for the transition to be a success
we must must leave no one behind
this is why the eu made the just
transition a key pillar of the european
green deal
and why we strongly endorse the
political declaration to support the
conditions for a just transition
internationally as well as the global
coal to clean power transition statement
you have just heard about our just
energy transition partnership with south
africa this is one way we are putting
our commitments into practice
to learn about others i invite you all
to attend the events we are organizing
tomorrow
at the eu pavilion together with the
international energy agency where we
will present concrete measures we are
taking to support a global justin
session i look forward to working with
all of you to make
the just transition
a success
thank you
commissioner simpson thank you very much
indeed and now if i could please call
upon
minister bernali from morocco if you
could go to the other lectern please
thank you very much um excellencies
ladies and gentlemen
uh it's really a real pleasure that the
kingdom of morocco participates in this
historic moment and flagship event that
we have today
um on the inc an inclusive and fair
energy transition and i would like on
this occasion to reiterate my
congratulations to the united kingdom
for the quality of the organization amid
covet 19 indeed
and the relevance of the themes that we
have during the course of these two
weeks
uh talking about morocco's experience
i think it's despite our low
responsibility in terms of
greenhouse gas emissions
we have revised as you know upward our
ambition with regard to the our ndc's by
reducing our greenhouse gas emissions by
more than 45
by 2030 instead of the 42 that we had
before
as part of our integrated strategy of
low carbon development by 2050.
um our commitment i think i'm not going
to re reiterate our commitments for a
low carbon energy transition that
started actually more than a decade ago
based on three pillars renewable
energies
energy efficiency and strengthening
regional integration and i'll come back
to that later
and of course we accompany that with a
strong orientation for adapted
innovation and some local content
uh it's a proactive political choice
made by his majesty the king muhammad 6
and it has generated the dynamic
among dynamic among all political and
economic actors as well as civil society
today we have
50 renewable energy projects with an
installed capacity of 4 gigawatts
already in service
and we have more than 60 projects that
are under development and under
construction
but that is not enough
it's important to note these projects
are made possible thanks to our existing
institutional regulatory framework that
we are and we are working 24 7 to uh
streamline that regulatory uh framework
and improve the guidelines improve the
business climate and facilitate
investments from the national
investments and international
investments as well
we have made progress in uh the impact
of just an energy transition on social
economic plans we already have
two platforms in terms of r d innovation
and industrializations that are already
in operation
um dedicated to green technologies green
buildings and smart grids and we have
other developments including of course
in hydrogen in energy recovery from
biomass and the water energy agriculture
nexus
we are also witnessing an emergence of a
local industrial ecosystem that we are
pushing forward
and the rise of renewable energies and
decentralized production is enable us to
really use uh these these developments
for the
for the specific needs of many social
economic needs but here again it is not
enough
we have we are reviewing rather than
reviewing our energy strategy to provide
a greener energy mix by 2030
based on again energy efficiency but we
are focusing particularly on the
industrial and tertiary sectors and the
promotion of sustainable mobility in
addition to energy saving
potential of
more than 20
by 2030.
how to accelerate that inclusive and
just energy transition
i think
it's necessary to have control over the
impact to minimize the technological and
financial risks and to maximize the
social economic benefits especially at
the local and regional level
i will finish by saying
if we don't want
new
call as far as morocco is concerned
there is no energy transition without a
stronger international and regional
cooperation to promote green
technologies of course hydrogen
applications but to really increase
connectivity between our neighbors
and our trade partners
i would like to finish by reiterating my
thanks and we support the different
initiatives that were announced at this
cup which are with cop 26 which are
aligned with our strategic vision and
development model thank you very much
minister bernali thank you very much
indeed and now if i could call on sri
lanka and minister di sanayaki
good morning
ministers distinguished guests and
ladies and gentlemen
it is pleasure to be here with all of
you today
i present the beautiful island sri lanka
where nature and the planet are
singularly addressed as the mother a
beautiful mother she has given so much
a lot of sun a lot of rain and the
unimaginable scale of biodiversity both
in fauna and flora we have taken good
care of her trading so much very
lightly
contributing just
one of 2000 to the emission burn
of the planet from human activities
we reaffirm that
fragility will remain as our way of life
in the future too
however we have taken some great
initiatives to reduce even the small
contribution from sri lanka to the
emission burden of the planet
considering energy sector as a notable
contribution to the emissions we have
taken all possible measures to
accelerate the energy transition we
anticipate to generate 70 percent of our
electricity from renewable energy
resources by 2030
doubling our 36 percent share of the
renewables in power generation today
this requires an additional of
9000 megawatts of clean renewable energy
capacity leading to an annual elixir
generation of 21 000
gigahertz gigawatt hours
translating to an investment of 10
billion us dollars
it will contribute to an annual co2
emission reduction of 14 million
tons by
way of avoiding petroleum fuel based
electric regeneration
our effect does not end here
and it encompasses demand side
management too
we also anticipate the national energy
efficiency improvement and conversation
conservation program to reduce the
energy demand so that our clean energy
targets will be realized quicker and the
grain realized will be sustained
with these efforts
we are trading towards carbon neutrality
in the energy sector by 2050.
we anticipate a further addition of 6000
megawatts from renewable energy sources
to cater to the fossil fuel demand
dislocked by transport electrification
which will gain be supported by
transport energy demand reduction
measures
we have proposed our
ambitious target in the nationality
demand determine contributions where we
invite the spirited cooperation of
developed economies
to
realize that 20
supported indices
it is our sincere hope that developed
economies and the green funds will
reduce the transaction burden of these
fund fellows and technology transfer
making it easier for the developing
world to access those
we
earnestly request you to develop simpler
tools and hassle-free
conduits to allow funds and technology
to reach
the developing world with the
amount of lease delay so urgent actions
can be taken to reduce the present and
future emissions burdens from the
developing economy thank you thank you
for all
presents here today thank you
minister
thank you very much indeed and if i can
now call on grenada and minister steele
thank you
colleagues friends a very warm good
morning
as a small island developing state in
the caribbean which neither produces nor
consumes coal
you may ask
who am i to add my voice to this
conversation
the answer is a simple one
the single most impactful intervention
we can implement today
to significantly bend the curve
to a 1.5 pathway
this is why we must consign
coal
to history
we can we commend
those who have already taken important
steps
countries that have committed to coal
phase out dates and um and announcements
to end
i have some technology challenges here
we commend those who have already taken
important steps countries that have
committed to coal phase out dates and
announcements to end in phase
financing of coal projects abroad
but we still have a long way to go the
longer this takes
the less likely we are to achieving our
goal to limiting warming to 1.5
we know what needs to be done
for richer countries
no more coal power from 2030
and all coal-fired power stations shut
by 2040 at the latest
but the question then is how do we
achieve a just an inclusive transition
when globally
we still have close to a billion people
without access to electricity
here is where some of the different
questions need to be answered
there are those that say we should
transition to gas
and the gas is a bridging fuel
let's be honest this is a bridge to
nowhere
gas needs to peak now and begin
a rapid decline
we have much cheaper and cleaner
alternatives in the form of renewable
energy and storage
and green hydrogen is coming
fossil fuel subsidies are propping up
coal and gas
what a wasted opportunity when you
consider the renewables that could be
rolling out with that money
and the jobs that come with it
speaking as a small voice
from a small island
even more creative solutions are needed
than those currently on the table
what is required is unprecedented levels
of cooperation and genuine resolve
between those in the g20
individually and
collectively as a group that generates
75 percent of global emissions
and constitutes 80 percent of global gdp
between them
this issue can be resolved
if they don't
then who will
and this is why we're all here
as individual nations
with all our domestic challenges and
complexities
but we're also here as a global
community with the power the wealth
and the mandate
to do what is needed collectively
the future of countries like mine depend
on whether or not coal seams around the
world are left as they are
and this is why grenada lends its
support
to the clean energy transition
initiative and commends today's launch
of the just transition declaration
for my island
it is a once-in-a-lifetime opportunity
to leapfrog the energy systems of our
grandparents
to create a new energy system that is
fit for our children i thank you
minister steele thank you very much
indeed and now to hear from another
island nation
minister shauna from the maldives
thank you
excellencies ladies and gentlemen
allow me to congratulate the cop
presidency and the secretariat for the
impossible work that you have done in
making us
come here and be in attendance in person
thank you to the uk for their leadership
in getting us all here safely
we came to cop because this is our
lifeline
excellencies
the maldives climate and energy
challenges are enormous
the maldives depends almost entirely on
imported fossil fuels in meeting our
energy energy needs
the imported diesel
costs us a fortune
leaving us at the mercy of volatile
global energy markets
our islands are scattered across the sea
making economies of scale impossible
considering this and despite the fact
that maldi's fossil fuel emissions are
relatively negligible
it is perhaps no surprise that the
government's policy is to quit fossil
fuels as quickly as possible and replace
them with something the maldives has in
abundance
sunshine
today 12 percent of our energy
is coming from renewables
as a country on the front line of the
climate crisis a transition to
renewables is not just about mitigation
but also about adaptation and building
resilience
to achieve this transformation from an
economy run on diesel to one powered by
the sun will require substantial amounts
of foreign capital and investments
it also need reliable data and
innovative technology
we are working to install
floating solar in our lagoons
the science is so clear
the technology is available the prices
are declining
we just need access to these
world leaders
negotiators
funding agencies
all of us are here today
but the planet does not have room for
animal negotiations
we just have to decarbonize
we have to keep it under 1.5 the
difference between 1.5 degrees and 2
degrees for countries like the maldives
is a death sentence
we have to give away those hard
positions we have been holding on to for
the past decades
i don't like to think of the maldives
and small islands
as victims alone we can also be victims
we have been part of the energy
transition we are coming out of a
pandemic
we
we found the vaccines
treat climate emergency like an
emergency and i am confident that we can
all do this together but even if we go
net zero just this year it won't save us
because this is not a unilateral issue
we need the entire world to get behind
the science and transition
to a world fueled by renewables thank
you
minister shauna thank you very much
indeed
ministers commissioner thank you very
much for your words fantastic to hear
those clean uh transition commitments so
i can i ask you please to leave the
stage you can join your seats in the
plenary
on the plenary floor thank you very much
indeed
[Applause]
now i am delighted to introduce our next
speaker the special representative of
the un secretary general
and the ceo of sustainable energy for
all damalola ogumbayi damalola please
over to you
your excellencies ladies and gentlemen
it is my pleasure to be here with you
all today
on behalf of the un secretary general
i'd like to thank the cop president alok
sharma and his team for their efforts
for prioritizing energy here at cop 26
including through the energy transition
council and the great work the team
there have been doing energy accounts
for over two-thirds of greenhouse gas
emissions
but at the same time
759 million people
in this world still lack access to basic
electricity
and over 2.6 billion don't even have
access to clean cooking solutions
over the next nine years we have to do
two things at once
first we must cut emissions drastically
the emissions gap report just released
by the un
environment told us the new and updated
ndcs only take 7.5 percent off predicted
twenty thirty emissions
while fifty five percent is needed to
achieve the paris agreement
second
we must deliver on the promise we made
in the sustainable development goal 7
to provide affordable reliable
sustainable and modern energy to all by
if we are to do this by 2030 we need to
radically rethink how we deliver energy
services
we must answer the call of the un
secretary general and cop president to
co-sign coal into history starting with
the oecd countries by 2030 and globally
by 2040.
after 2021 no new core plans should be
in the pipeline which is also reflected
in the great work that has been seen
from the global call to clean power
transition statement
if this year is the year we put an end
to coal
this must also be the year that we prove
to developing countries the clean energy
is the most attractive and most
affordable option by providing them a
clean energy offer
and we must do this through technical
assistance collaboration and making
finance for clean energy
dramatically easier to access
we must show why clean energy is an
important part of the blueprint for
sustainable future and move beyond
thinking the providing clean energy for
basic household is enough
it must be energy
for businesses economic growth and
industrial development
consider the alternative right now we're
on track for
degree temperature rise and by 2030 we
will still leave over 600 million people
without electricity
and over 2.3 billion people without
clean cooking this is not compatible
with the commitments we made of paris
or is it compatible with the promise we
made in 2015 to achieve sustainable
development goals by 2030
we are running out of time so we have no
choice but to be
decisive and we commit to the
collaboration and financing necessary to
make just
equitable
and inclusive energy transitions
possible for those who have contributed
the least to climate change
together we are the architects of a
sustainable future for all and on behalf
of the secretary general i want to thank
all of you gathered here for all the
great work you have done and committing
to all the work ahead thank you
thank you very much indeed we now turn
to the second part of our event
which is a panel discussion between
ministers from countries that are
actively pursuing a just and inclusive
energy transition and international
experts from the international labour
organization and international trade
union congress
to chair this panel i am delighted to
introduce vic van vieren director for
enterprise at the international labour
organisation vic
thank you very much and uh good mor good
morning everybody it was very exciting
for me as a south african to hear the
opening remarks and the deal that's just
been done with uh president cyril
ramaphosa i look forward to going home
and seeing the progress
but your excellencies ladies and
gentlemen
it gives me great pleasure to welcome
the panelists on stage and i'll
introduce them now and then
we will go one by one as after i've made
a few opening remarks uh on my right the
secretary of state uh mr quasi quarten
from the united kingdom
on his right secretary jennifer granholm
from the united states
and on my left miss sharon burrow the
general secretary of the international
trade union confederation
we also have two video inserts that we
will hear from minister vice president
teresa rivera of spain and also minister
svenja schultz from germany
the panel is said to discuss the just
transition declaration that the uk cop
26 presidency has spearheaded under the
energy transition council
the ilo has been privileged to
contribute to the work of the council
a just energy transition is urgent
indispensable and possible
it's about maximizing economic and
social gains while effectively managing
the risks of the economic technological
and social transformation
the good news is that we have a positive
narrative
there is clear evidence of more gains
for the economy and people than losses
comprehensive and coherent policy
frameworks aligning energy economic and
social policies are indispensable
representatives of governments
workers and employers organizations some
time back at the ilo developed
guidelines for a just transition for all
providing a policy guiding framework and
practical tools for countries
the just transition declaration that
we're talking about today reflects
several elements of the guidelines and
represents a solid foundation to build
upon
it now gives me great pleasure to
introduce secretary kwa tang from the uk
who's announced
and uh secretary clinton the the uk has
announced that it will phase out coal
from great britain's energy system by
the year 2024
what plans are the uk putting forward
for a transformation grounded on the
imperatives of a just transition and the
creation of decent work around the
around the world i hand the flow over to
you uh thank you so much uh vic it's
great to hear
uh from you and also to be at this uh
forum
uh this morning
uh colleagues uh it's clear
to us all uh that to keep
uh 1.5 degrees uh in reach
we need to consign coal to history
and make clean energy our future
but of course beyond uh the climate
imperative there is a green industrial
revolution out there
within our grasp
that promises huge economic
opportunities for our people
and our communities
we have we want to see revitalized
industries
new sustainable jobs
increased
prosperity
and healthier and more resilient
societies
it's important that we uh push and
harness the benefits from this huge
economic shift
so that nobody
is left behind
each country gathered here today
is unique and faces its own
uh unique set of challenges so while we
must
accelerate
the coal to clean power transition
globally
and keep 1.5 degrees within reach
there is no
one-size-fits-all
approach
yes
we have as you say vic had a rapid
transition
uh from dirty coal power generation
uh to a cleaner
greener approach
it has been uh remarkable i think uh but
it's also presented challenges and we
recognize
uh that the pace in different countries
uh will be slightly different
we know that our net zero futures
are reliant on more than just uh
technologies changing but also in the
way
we
change in the way we live and work
together
so
we must build this low carbon transition
with the people most affected
and also provide
ways in which
local communities
and workers can be involved directly
in the decisions
that affect
their future so whether you're a coal
miner in south africa indonesia or
colombia you want to know what your
future will look like
what the future holds for your community
and your children and i'm delighted
actually that we've launched the 8.5
billion dollar uh just energy transition
partnership with your uh country uh vic
south africa alongside our u.s german
french
and eu
partners this long-term partnership has
the potential to support south africa to
reach the most ambitious uh target
possible uh within its updated
nationally determined uh contribution
i think that
this partnership actually will provide
a a template a blueprint for how we can
collaborate on energy transitions
uh with coal intensive
uh economies
um when i look at the
partnership uh that we've announced with
south africa i look i see that the
skills of a minor today will be needed
to extract uh the minerals that go into
uh solar panels that'll power our lives
tomorrow so that's an example of the
just
transition and i think the commitments
in this just transition declaration
seek to provide a framework for
developed countries to assist
developing countries and emerging
economies
as they
transition this work
is absolutely critical we can only
achieve a net zero future for the world
if we all move uh away from coal and
towards uh greener energy
sources and it isn't just about
government
it's not just governments that are
making a difference actors from all
areas are pushing and driving uh this
just transition and we welcome the
efforts of the ilo
uh our panel moderator uh this morning
and the iea and irena in their recent
work as well as the work of the uh cifs
in supporting uh inclusive and just uh
transitions
uh during our cop 26 uh presidency the
uk will continue to work closely with
all our international partners to
strengthen
and uh
progress
uh global climate action
thank you
thank you uh secretary kwa tang
it now gives me great pleasure to turn
to secretary granholm
secretary the us administration has
reengaged with the global climate agenda
with a massive plan for climate action
job creation and just transition
how does the u.s view a just transition
and what are your plans for implementing
it great thank you vic so much and my
thanks to state secretary cortang and
the entire uk delegation for their
incredible work in organizing this
declaration
so we've all talked about it we all know
that we face a great challenge in
eliminating carbon pollution and
avoiding the worst impacts of climate
change but as has pent said the
opportunity
at hand is
even greater
clean energy is an engine that will get
us to our net zero future and bring all
communities along fossil communities
front line communities i know this
because i have seen it firsthand just
quickly a personal experience
in 2009 of course the great recession
tore through particularly the american
auto industry an industry that was
reliant of course upon the eternal
combustion engine
hundreds of thousands lost their jobs in
the state of michigan where i was
governor
we had the highest unemployment rate in
the nation the pain that i saw
in the eyes of workers
who had the rug pulled out from under
them through no fault of their own that
pain has seared
my soul i became obsessed with how we
can create
jobs in clean energy to diversify our
economy and with
large federal and state and private
sector investments we in michigan began
focusing on
electric vehicles and their supply
chains the batteries the guts to those
vehicles and employment
rebounded as we re-anchored local
economies all across the state and today
michigan is a national leader in ev
manufacturing the internal combustion
engine companies set their sights now on
one half of their fleets being electric
by 2030.
line workers who once assembled those
gas powered vehicles are now building
electric trucks and an industry that was
once dependent on fossil fuels is
accelerating toward the clean energy
future
president biden is quintupling down on
the investment strategy that enabled
michigan's shift all told his build back
better agenda will invest over 800
billion dollars in clean energy and
climate action
that is an historic amount
and it's all about growing the pie by
orders of magnitude through clean energy
build out creating jobs jobs and more
jobs jobs in solar and wind and hydro
power and nuclear that'll ease the
burdens of carbon pollution jobs and evs
and batteries and storage that'll get
factories humming jobs in carbon capture
and geothermal and clean hydrogen
that'll demand skills that fossil fuel
workers already have jobs for
electricians and technicians and and
carpenters and engineers and miners and
smelters and steel workers and line
workers and a whole host of journeymen
and women
our goal is not simply replacing one
industry with another it's using the
enormous talent within our communities
to build a more diversified resilient
economy that can address
long-standing inequities by the way
and one that can offer stability and
sustainability and safety to all who
take part and one big enough for anyone
and everyone who wants to take part
the global market
for clean energy technologies
will be 23 trillion dollars by 2030
23 trillion dollars
that's what's on the other side of this
transition
truly sustainable economic growth that
will keep expanding as other countries
jump into this market
that's why we are pledging support for
developing nations as they work to stake
their own claims in this clean energy
opportunity and in many respects the us
is catching up to the uk and other
countries who've been working toward
these goals
for years
we are eager to play our part in this
global effort to build a more resilient
equitable economy we are back and we are
ready to partner
thank you
thank you very much uh secretary
grenholm i'm now going to turn to my
left and welcome to the podium or to the
to the
table
minister aslam from pakistan minister
could you please share with us the
pakistan's perspectives on transition in
the national context thank you the floor
is yours
uh this village rahim and thank you uh
excellency and
uh i think
i would like to start off by thanking
the uk government for really convening
this dialogue which has gone on for the
last few months on clean energy
transition and this has really been
instrumental in creating the momentum
that we have
over here right now and and bringing
forward some
real-life solutions and i'll talk to you
about that as i speak
pakistan is a country which is really
uh not one of the big uh uh
you know carbon polluters we are less
than one percent of the global carbon
emissions
but we have decided that we do not want
to be a part of the problem going
forwards you want to be a part of the
solution going forward to the issue of
climate change and a major part of that
leads to
uh you know shifting towards clean
energy so our prime minister imran khan
made a very bold statement when he set
out to target that by 2030 pakistan
in its energy mix would have 60
clean
zero carbon energy and that you know it
relates to hydro power wind power
solar power and also nuclear power
i think
it is a direction that
we need the world to take and this
direction has to be taken in the next
decade because if you don't
2060 2070 might be too late for climate
change and we might already already be
on a pathway of of self-destruction
so so pakistan on this energy transition
pathway is not just
talking the talk but we were also
walking the talk immediately after we
made this announcement
we had two projects which were both
based on imported coal about 24 hundred
megawatts of that and they had been
financially closed but we shared those
projects both of them and we shifted to
3 700 megawatts of clean hydro energy at
the same time we came up with another
announcement uh which was that we will
not have any more imported coal projects
in pakistan
and and i would like to say over here
that you know for us it is still the
least cost option
but when we think of climate change and
the uh effects of
air pollution and the health
effects of having that sort of pathway
in pakistan it makes complete sense to
get off it and then to get on to a
cleaner a more healthier pathway not
only for pakistan but also for the world
i also want to share two indicators
which which really show uh the pathway
that we are taking the world bank came
out with some uh you know very
interesting uh indicators uh uh about
two weeks back they did a screening of
their lending portfolio and pakistan is
one of the big
receiving countries to see which are the
countries which are really
putting
development onto
carbon friendly and and climate-friendly
pathways and i'm glad to say that
pakistan topped that list we had 44 of
our mainstream development funding
climate being climate friendly and a
major part of that
linked up with clean energy transition
that we are making
uh similarly the ndc that we have
we had
given a business as usual pathway in
2016. we updated the ndc this year and
we have shown that in 2020 we have
already gone down nine percent from
business as usual uh uh
in our ndc and we've given uh a pathway
in which
by 2030
we can drop it a further 15
below our business as usual and the real
uh gauntlet that we have thrown is is
just to the world and we have said that
pakistan is willing to drop it
to 50 of
below business as usual if we get
climate finance the same climate finance
that we've been talking about over the
last decade that finance if it becomes
available and with the right
technologies we can drop it to uh you
know
below business as usual and we've set
out the projects it's a 100 billion
dollar portfolio over a 10-year period
that we require to make this shift
finally i would just like to say that
you know when we talk about energy
transition it has to be adjust energy
transitions one of the gaps in this
whole story was that
what about countries who are already on
uh you know polluting pathways and they
want to unlock
themselves out of those projects for
instance pakistan has got
some imported gold projects which is
less than 10 of our energy portfolio but
they're still there
and if you want to you know close them
down today we still have to cater for
for the
uh ipp agreements the ppa agreements uh
which mandate you know state-sponsored
guarantees for
caps capacity payments even if you close
down those projects so that was a gap in
this whole scenario and that's where i
really want to thank the uk government
because when you held this dialogue in
that dialogue
we i actually heard of this mechanism
called the energy transition mechanism
for the first time uh it is being uh
you know it's an innovative out of the
box instrument which is going to target
a transition
of projects which are already in the
pipeline and which are you know belching
out carbon to retire those projects and
shift to clean energy megawatt to
megawatt without penalizing the
government that's the most important
part because otherwise you should do it
you you have to pay a financial cost so
so
when i heard about that i got in touch
with adb and today this afternoon we are
going to be signing
up as pakistan being one of the you know
three pilot countries to be testing that
instrument in pakistan uh for that shift
so you know if i was not on that
dialogue i would not have heard about
this and this would not have happened
so uh i think
we need the world
to make this transition but this
transition has to be just so that
countries like pakistan who want to
go along this pathway are not paying out
of their pocket it is something which is
good not only good for them but also
good for the world so that you know
delta has to be covered and i i believe
this this instrument is is trying to do
that uh so we have signed up and uh uh
you know if it happens in pakistan it
will really be something that the world
can also then follow thank you very much
thank you minister we're now going to
listen to a video message from vice
president teresa rivera of spain
the jazz transition agenda is not only
an agenda to preserve and to go along
the different polluting industries to
get into something much more clear much
more clean to get energy and industrial
er
response to the challenges of becoming
climate neutral a digestion system
agenda as i say is something much more
deep it is something that connects to
people it is something that has the
people in the center of the
decision-making process it is something
that pay attention to the opportunities
that any citizen in the world in terms
of access to jobs the capacity to build
new opportunities in those
local and regions local areas and
regions where the coal and other
polluting industries used to be the main
economic central piece of the economic
activity have to transform into
something different we need to ensure
that the well-being and the benefit of
all citizens are part of this discussion
and are properly tackled by the
different governments the social and
equity considerations are key when
defining a jazz transition agenda we
need to preserve from the negative
effects of the climate transformation
but at the same time we need to ensure a
message of hope a message of
transformational agenda full of
opportunities for those being effective
of this transformation the social cost
of carbon the carbon dividend needs to
be reinvested on people needs to be
reinvested in local communities need to
define a set of responses that are
accepted and built with the local
communities so to ensure that any
citizen takes part of the definition of
the future to come in the regions
this is what it has been at the core of
our just transition strategy this is why
in spain we have invested so much and so
long in the proper definition of what we
want to do in each of the local areas
where a coal plant is being phased out
defining where the different neighbors
the different local authorities the
different workers have
properly identified
the opportunities they add value of what
they want to be in this
in this in this context what we have
done is to work to lower to facilitate
to avoid the social tensions but at the
same time we need positive action we
need a positive discrimination so to
facilitate through different measures
that this becomes an attractive
destination for new investments so that
this means that citizens workers do want
to stay and you have an opportunity to
stay with a decent job being in the
origin and this is something that can
generate still different tensions as we
have been witnessing in the turbulence
due to the high electricity prices
transitioning from the benefits of one
system to the benefits of the new system
require much attention to the social
dimension and the transitional costs and
opportunities of this transformation
consumers and workers need to be in the
center of our decision-making process we
need to build this inclusive capitalism
but we need to pay attention to the
social media measures to the equity and
solidarity
aspects the cost is unacceptable when it
is always paid on the shoulders of
workers and consumers the other way
around we need business being involved
in a sincere but in a constructive
manner it is not just a question of
fiscal and economic benefits it's a
question of investment on people
thank you to vice president teresa
rivera of spain
we're now going to listen to our second
video message of from minister svenja
schultz of germany
colleagues ladies and gentlemen
our energy systems must be completely
decarbonized in a few years time to
achieve the goals of the paris agreement
we are all familiar with the challenges
this brings
we have come together in glasgow to take
the next steps
decarbonizing our economies
opens up great opportunities if the
transition is just
inclusive and comprehensive germany will
be climate neutral by 2045
phasing out coal-fired power generation
is the first step
society and industry support this phase
out along with the face out of nuclear
power
in germany we involved workers
businesses civil society communities and
other stakeholders in this decision
in future we will continue to work on
the energy transition together
and this requires support for example
structural policies that promote
innovation continuing education programs
and the modernization of infrastructure
this support pays off for those affected
and for the energy transition
as a supporter of the global call to
clean power transition statement
and the declaration on supporting the
conditions for a just transition
internationally
germany has renewed its commitment to
close cooperation
cooperation at all levels with other
countries and with stakeholders
sustainable inclusive energy supply has
long been a priority of germany's
international cooperation work
recent examples include germany's major
contributions to the accelerating coal
transition program of the climate
investment funds and two new projects in
the federal environment ministry
these projects have received funding of
almost 40 million euros
the first project focuses on work on
just transition and building a global
network for knowledge transfer with
partners in affected regions in india
and indonesia
the second as a project we are planning
with partners in south africa to support
core regions there
the aim is a just transition from
promoting coal to sustainable economic
activity
just transition creates a secure and
fair future
it is a historic opportunity
to achieve sustainable prosperity for
all thank you very much
thank you minister schulzer
i'm now going to turn to our last
panelist in this discussion um
miss sharon barrow from i took
sharon the trade unions have been at the
forefront of the agenda for a just
transition including its uptake in the
paris agreement at this point in time
what would you see as a missing piece of
the puzzle making this just transition a
reality
over to you
thanks vic well we know we're all we all
know we're in a race against time for a
sustainable future for both people and
the planet clean energy is the
foundation for the vital transitions in
heavy industry and transport in
construction in agriculture in our
cities and our homes
the trade unions with the ituc the
global union federations we are totally
committed to climate ambition but it
must also be in parallel with just
transition
there can be no stranded workers and no
stranded communities
we know that there is no future for coal
that's painful for our workers we know
there must be a near exit date from all
fossil fuels that's painful for workers
but the answer is jobs jobs jobs and
jobs the good news is vic that there are
jobs in renewable energy for every 10
jobs in renewable energy there are 5 to
10 in manufacturing supply chains and if
they're good jobs with just wages there
are 30 to 35 in the broader economy in
fact with the world resources institute
the ituc just released a jobs study
called the green advantage and it shows
dollar for dollar pound-for-pound
investment in clean energy production
returns at least two jobs to one
compared to fossil fuels
so as i said jobs jobs and jobs
jobs good jobs with just transition
this is the key to build trust and
support in the speed of shifts required
we need national jobs plans but we also
need company jobs plans plans agreed
through social dialogue in line with the
ilo guidelines
we also need to make sure for older
workers that there are secure pensions
and for all others that there is income
support skills and redeployment support
through the process of transition
and we cannot ignore we cannot ignore
community renewal where people must have
a say in their future
indeed the south african partnership
is founded in a good framework there is
a national jobs plan it's been
negotiated for a just recovery through
ned lac their national social dialogue
structure
there's now a work and community impact
study from s-com the utility that is
responsible for shifting the
the the country from coal and now there
are
negotiations with unions for an aligned
plan for jobs in the company and for
communities with those affected that's a
model we need to emulate everywhere we
thank the uk government for coordinating
the just transition declaration building
on the silesia declaration this is so
important with its commitments to leave
no one behind
and today i can tell you that the c40
the b team and the ituc
released a joint statement on just
transition and the energy crisis
teresa rivera raised it this statement
puts forward a united front of mayors
unions and business
calling for government leadership to
assist all actors in the two urban uh
crisis for urban residents
one is of course climate crisis and
indeed the jobs issue the other is
aspiring energy prices both of these
things sit at the heart of just
transition and vic in conclusion i
acknowledge the iaea principles and
thank the governments and the ia for
working with us and civil society
to give those guiding principles life
and the critical message here the
critical message from everyone is
integrating the urgent urgency of action
with just transition it will take all of
us so let's get on the job
thank you
thank you sharon
and thank you to all our panelists for
their excellent presentations this
morning you know coming to the cop
meetings at the beginning of of the week
or just before i came i go for a walk
every morning
i live in a little village just outside
of geneva
and i go very early in the morning and
it's at five o'clock and it's still dark
and as i walk through
the forest area with the trees forming a
guard around me
and the cloud forming a covering over my
head there was a gentle breeze that
opened up the sky
and the stars were shining so bright
that it felt like i could pluck one off
from the sky like plucking an apple from
a tree
and it made me think about the
importance of these discussions
that we need to reflect on the value of
a human being and the value of our
planet
because this is what this is all about
and it made me think of my six
grandchildren and wondering whether they
would also experience what i've
experienced on the beauty of this planet
and then we once we've reflected on that
we can then recognize the importance of
these political and technical
discussions
and the future implications it has
for all of us and our families across
the globe
i wish to thank the uk government an
appreciation and our gratitude to our
panel members
and uh for the uk and its cop presidency
for this highly important initiative and
one that creates optimism and hope as we
leave at the end of this week so thank
you very much and i hand back to louisa
vic thank you very much vic vande van
vieren from the international labour
organisation and thank you to all your
speakers
if you could now please leave the stage
and join your seats in the plenary and
you'll see quasi-quatern has remained we
are going to hear some closing remarks
now from the secretary of state at the
department for business energy and
industrial strategy secretary of state
yes please
[Applause]
uh thank you
vic
for chairing that
interesting lovely discussion brilliant
discussion
and also thank you to louisa for
inviting me to make concluding remarks
i've been really
interested and stimulated this morning
to hear
the progress
to scale up the deployment of clean
power
to end
investment
in new coal and indeed to phase out
coal power and support a just
transition
recognizing that communities must be at
the heart
of that endeavor
this progress that we're making means
that for the first time
we can actually see
that the end of unabated coal power
is
in view
and is attainable
when i was growing up in london in the
1980s
coal was ubiquitous
coal provided
over 70 percent
of britain's electricity generation
today
that coal
which provided so much power for britain
in the 20th century
that coal provides less than two percent
of our electricity
and it will be phased out completely by
2024.
we've taken massive strides to cut
emissions while growing our economy
and we've also seen
workers our workers
and workers
over
all over the world taking existing
skills and employ them in new decent
local
jobs
but as we've said
in this session each country
is different
but i hope sincerely that many of our
friends and our neighbors
across the world can learn from lessons
that we've learned here in the uk
uh as a government we believe that it is
an undeniable truth
that competition
innovation
and entrepreneurialism
uh within a market framework can lead
and will lead to new and better products
services
and technologies at lower cost for
industry and consumers
public money alone we must remember will
not be enough to end our contribution to
climate change by 2050 we need to
leverage trillions
in private capital to develop new
technologies uh to lower emissions we
must now join together to scale that
process up and to speed up things up
that's why through the glasgow power
break through world leaders uh set out
this week that's why these commitments
are so important
the glasgow power breakthrough i think
provides a new ambition for how working
together we can make clean power the
most affordable accessible and reliable
option for all countries to meet their
power needs efficiently by
2030 making the 2020s a decade of
delivery with an unprecedented
acceleration
of both the innovation and deployment of
clean technology we need
today uh on energy
uh day
uh we will hear more from a number of
international coalitions driving the
coalition
uh the alliance uh from coal to clean
power we will hear uh from the energy
transition council we will hear about
the green grids uh initiative one sun
one world one grid and of course the
powering past coal alliance i want to
thank them
and i want to thank cop 26's principal
partners from the energy sector ssc
scottish power and national grid for
their continuing support
we can't rewrite the past
some of the damage that we've already
wrought upon climate is sadly
irreversible
but we can
write a new chapter that changes how the
story ends i think the potential rewards
of the green industrial revolution are
truly transformational
and with the right approach will benefit
everybody in the global community we
will consign coal to history and we will
move together to a cleaner more
sustainable and more prosperous future
thank you all very much
secretary of state thank you very much
indeed for your motivational words thank
you very much
well that
concludes the opening event of energy
day
but we will be back here in the
cairngorn room for two further events as
the secretary of state alluded to
at 11 30 there is an event hosted by the
energy transition council making the
global transition to clean power a
reality
and then at 3 30 that event hosted by
the powering past coal alliance
called powering the world past coal
for now please could you exit promptly
so that the whole of the room can be
cleaned and i hope to see you at the
next event thank you
the power sector is responsible for a
quarter of global emissions
more than any other sector
but a global transition to clean power
is already underway
and it is accelerating
by 2020 renewable power has risen to
make up over one quarter of global
generation
and is increasingly driving job creation
and economic growth
meanwhile
in the last decade
the number of people living without
access to electricity has almost half
countries are abandoning plans to build
new coal plants that they don't need
since the paris agreement the global
coal pipeline has collapsed by three
quarters
this year the no new coal power compact
was launched led by sri lanka and chile
along with five other countries
pakistan the philippines and malaysia
have all announced that they are
stopping the building of new coal plants
and the asia climate vulnerable forum
has expressed its support for this
position
this here has also seen commitments from
the g7
the republic of korea and china to end
international financing for new coal
power
together with this growing political
momentum
the economics of the power sector have
continued to shift
smarter greener grids are enabling
higher shares of renewables and it is
increasingly becoming cheaper to install
new renewables rather than continue to
operate existing coal plants
the asian development bank has created
the first ever financing facility to
support countries in realizing this
opportunity by retiring their coal
plants early
the coalition of countries committed to
fully phasing out corporate continues to
grow
this year
the powering past coal alliance grew to
41 countries including spain
north macedonia and hungary
and it's not just countries doing their
part
235 energy companies have now joined the
race to zero 14 utilities are members of
the powering past call alliance
along with over 20 financial
institutions
creating a growing list of investors
committed to phasing out calls from
their portfolios
the global energy alliance for people
and planet joins philanthropies public
and private sectors to help ensure the
benefits of clean energy access are
truly universal with the creation of the
energy transition council the political
financial and technological leaders of
the global power sector have come
together to make sure that for every
country considering new power generation
claim power is the most attractive
option and to ensure that countries
stepping out on the journey to make a
just and inclusive energy transition
away from coal enjoy the strong support
of the international community
there are still challenges to be
overcome on the way to making clean
power accessible to all and to kicking
out coal the dirtiest fossil fuel from
the global power sector
but this year
a tipping point has been passed
the transition is gathering peace
we are moving irreversibly to playing
powerful
and we are consigning coal to history
you